i want everybody to be feel comfortable
here
under any circumstances they will not be
turned away the only christian federally
qualified health center in las vegas
hope christian health center is a
nonprofit that focuses on helping the
uninsured
and undocumented at today's event they
were able to feed
1500 families they have two locations
and also have a mobile clinic that runs
every tuesday
one great aspect to this clinic is its
ability to treat a variety of different
patients
we can see newborns to elderly patients
we can see
any age range basically and we do offer
primary care doctor
visits which means physicals any sick
visits from primary care to women's
health they cover it all
the mobile clinic is specifically for
the uninsured free of charge and does
include lab work if needed
for the stationary clinics each patient
is screened ahead of time
and the cost is based off of the sliding
fee scale which is based on the
patient's income
and their number of dependents it's
critical in today's circumstances
many people are losing their jobs
they're unemployed
after 30 days they lose their insurance
and as
other organizations may be shrinking we
are actually expanding to meet the need
currently the center has six doctors on
staff and if you're worried about making
payments they will help you with a
payment plan
and hope christian health center is open
six days a week and you can check their
facebook page
and we will have their number up on our
website reporting in the studio madison
kimbrough 8 news now